Israel's recently appointed security
minister has visited the compound
housing the Al-Aqsa mosque in occupied
East Jerusalem a move Palestinians
describe as provocative itamar bengavir
was surrounded by Security Forces as he
toured the site which has religious
significance for both Muslims and Jews
Israel's former prime minister yalapid
had warned such a visit or put lives in
danger
all the southern Hyatt is that the
amount of olives in occupied East
Jerusalem and Sarah of course he is one
of the most controversial figures of the
new far-right government previously
convicted of inciting racism this seems
almost certain to inflame tensions
though
absolutely Neve I mean this decision to
visit was very clear from a few days ago
it just wasn't expected to be happening
uh this early and this soon uh he it was
a very short uh trip if you like to
Alexa Moss compound or known as Temple
Mount by the Jews it was quick it was
short and it was in the early hours of
this morning and that's no surprise
because of the provocation that it would
cause especially amongst the
Palestinians and not just Palestinians
but the Muslim world now he turned up
the idea was that he had to go through
security with police first it had to be
discussed discussed rather with
Netanyahu which happened on Monday but
the indication was that this wouldn't
happen until a few weeks time here he
was this morning he turned up he left
and before you knew it there was very
strong reaction we've had strong
reaction from the Palestinians who have
called it unprecedented provocation
we've also heard from Hamas in Gaza that
has made it clear clear that if this
happens they'd been saying this since
Monday if this happened they were
calling on Palestinian youth especially
to mobilize and do something about this
there's been a lot of discontent towards
this decision also on Monday we heard
from uh lapid who is the former prime
minister and now the leader of the
opposition within the uh Israeli a new
government now Ben gavier he is now the
national security minister but he also
has sweeping Powers over the police
which came as no surprise that this
decision would happen actually very
quickly and he has he turned up and
we're going to expect a lot of tension
from the Palestinians already security
has been set up amongst the Israelis he
also made a statement saying that he
wouldn't be in any way
he wouldn't be threatened in any way by
Hamas or any threats against the Israeli
government this is someone who is
pushing for the expansion of settlements
the new government the Israeli new
government is a far right wing
ultra-orthodox government and they've
made this their absolute priority we've
seen an increased amount of tension in
the last few weeks and we're definitely
expecting things to turn up further
throughout the day
sorry it's not been the best start of
the year to it has it there's been more
conflict in the occupied West Bank at
least one teenager has been killed after
Israeli forces entered the city of
Janine what more can you tell us about
that
absolutely
um the Israeli forces turned up in
Bethlehem to make an arrest at a refugee
camp in the process there was a lot of
confrontations between the Palestinians
and the Israelis and as a result a
teenager was shot in the chest and
killed now this is not the only place
where there have been confrontations the
same in Janine as well as on Monday
demolitions that happened in a village
very close to Janine where two uh
families two young Palestinians who
carried out an attack on an Israeli
checkpoint last September they were
killed in that incident but killed an
Israeli within that attack and as a
result the Israeli forces came in
demolished the homes of their families
this is something that's against
international law but a mechanism that
the Israelis have been using to teach
Palestinians a lesson if you like that's
what they've been saying and also they
say to prevent any further attacks this
obviously goes against it's what the
human rights organization says that
these punitive measures are actually
punishing the family rather than those
that carried out any of the attacks so
we're seeing a step up in tensions 2022
was the most violent year within the
occupied West Bank for Palestinians we
saw more than 200 Palestinians killed
within the tensions with the Israeli
forces
Sarah hayat and occupied East Jerusalem
many things